nearly 700,000 immigrants are protected
by daca and many of them are training
for high-level professional careers
Adriana Diaz is at Loyola University's
Stritch School of Medicine in Maywood
Illinois outside Chicago where a group
of future doctors is watching the daca
debate very nervously Adriana good
morning good morning this medical school
was the first to officially accept and
documented students back in 2014
they're currently 32 being trained here
now because of daca they can't study and
work here but they don't get citizenship
we sat down with three students who told
us what it's like to be at the top of
their academic game with no clear future
in sight every time I hear footsteps
outside my door like there's a part of
me that for a second things you know
should I open the door after almost 20
years living in the United States stay
sad Montelongo still worries immigration
agents could detain him at any moment
born in Mexico but raised in New Mexico
the 28 year old is the first
undocumented immigrant to pursue his PhD
and MD at Loyola University's medical
school but the soon-to-be doctor may
never be able to practice legally my
biggest fear is that maybe daca will
remain but there will be no way to go
beyond daca like there will be no
pathway to citizenship 27 year old
Alejandra Duran Arreola studied
chemistry in college in Savannah before
becoming one of the dreamers enrolled
here the news were my new Twitter
reminds you that at some level you are
not welcomed here I see the u.s. as my
home my community my people my peers
Bell si Garcia Monica's mother brought
her to the US illegally from Guatemala
when she was seven traveling for two
weeks by foot and car I feel like I
haven't done anything wrong I've gone to
school I've gotten good grades I do
community service and yet that gives me
no right in a sense we have always drawn
strength from being a nation of
immigrants President Obama enacted daca
as an executive order in 2012 to protect
undocumented immigrants who came here as
children critics call it an unlawful
program that lacked congressional
approval promotes illegal in the
raishin and takes away jobs what do you
say to folks who say this is a country
that has to have its borders it has to
have its laws and people have to follow
those laws if you had someone that yes
they entered the country illegally but
it was twenty or thirty years ago and
they're a productive member of their
community they're paying taxes you know
what is the logic behind deporting them
outside of just falling an arbitrary
rule the president has said that he
wants to find a solution for daca do you
believe him they're spending a lot of
back and forth you know this is gonna
happen then it doesn't happen then
something else happens
although the prospect of deportation is
real Alejandra says she's not going back
to Mexico if I had to go I wouldn't go
to Mexico
I will go to Europe or to Canada or any
other country that once doctors it's
actually funny how we want to stay here
it's because our families are here our
communities are here but at the end of
the day we're American trained almost
physicians any other country would jump
up to take any of us if lawmakers find
no solution for daca there's no clear
path for these students to complete
their training repay their loans or
practice medicine John Major Anna thanks